[music]
the decision on monday alone
already had or will lead to us
actually saving millions of tons of co2
that is a very, very important signal
we made progress again today
we have a
general
orientation towards the co2 reduction of trucks and buses under the chairman of the austrian council
this is also a very
important area which for the first time in the
european union is really subject to a
valuable set of rules there is
no alternative to climate protection
the costs of not acting will be
considerably higher than the costs of
trading the european union has
now shown ours
responsibility taken and delivered
and the live program
[music]
berlin